Es ist so peinlich war möchte echt, im boden versinken wir deutschen haben die klimakonferenz man
muss sagen vermasselt die ärmeren regionen der erde fühlen sich allein gelassen
fragwürdig war vor allem der deutsche auftritt hier wurde deutlich der damalige vorreiter in sachen klimapolitik hat mehr als ein paar kratzer abbekommen
Wir machen den faktencheck was hat die bonner klimakonferenz
wirklich gebracht und wie wird der kampf gegen den klimawandel jetzt konkret weitergehen das alles jetzt den blick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Heute aus berlin die klimakonferenz vor zwei jahren in paris war mit einem großen versprechen
Beendet die ganze welt staunte als die teilnehmenden staaten damals versprachen die erwärmung der erde auf einen wert deutlich unter zwei grad celsius
zu stoppen ein ehrgeiziges aber längst überfällige statement und
irgendwie war klar dass der gipfel in bonn nicht daran reichen könnte denn sind wir mal ehrlich die selbst gesteckten ziele der
190 teilnehmenden staaten waren
minimalistisch man wollte irgendwie die umsetzung
des pariser abkommens
weiter nach vorne bringen und ja
das hat auch in teilen geklappt es gibt nun einen ersten entwurf für ein regelbuch das beschreibt wie das pariser abkommen ab
2020 in die tat umgesetzt werden kann das muss jetzt soweit gekürzt werden dass es 2018
Im polnischen kattowitz final beschlossen und unterzeichnet werden kann ein erfolg zum feiern ist das noch lange nicht aber es gibt einige punkte
Die in bonn abgehakt werden konnten die vielleicht größte erfolg in bonn der druck auf die welt
Aus der klimaschädlichen kohle auszusteigen ist gestiegen kanada und großbritannien haben den start einer
globalen initiative verkündet sie wollen zusammen mit 20 anderen partnern den ausstieg aus der kohle angehen und die macht immerhin noch rund
40 prozent der energieversorgung weltweit aus dabei sind unter anderem mexiko frankreich und italien mehr als peinlich für uns
Deutschland ist nicht bei diesem anti kohle bündnis dabei und da flippe ich wirklich aus wenn christian lindner von der fdp bei den koalitionsverhandlungen
in berlin befürchtet dass wir durch die abschaltung von kohlekraftwerken zum stromimporteur 'nen genau von solchen
klimaschädlichen kohlestrom werden und atomkraft dann wirft das ein
erschreckendes bild auf die fdp von tuten und blasen keine ahnung und die wollen die geschicke der
bundesrepublik deutschland bestimmen ob man das stimmt nämlich nicht wir brauchen die kohle verstromung einzig und allein für die netzstabilität
Und da zeigt ja gerade ihnen masken australien wie man das einfach und smart mit batterie farben lösen kann
lieberlieber christian lindner erst informieren dann reden da wird einem echt angst und bange um deutschland deutschland hat in bonn eine andere initiative
präsentiert demnach sollen arme und betroffene menschen weltweit
gegen klimaschäden versichert werden extreme wetterlagen in diesem jahr wie die hurricanes in der karibik oder die
dürren in teilen afrikas könnten zu führen dass 2017 ein neues rekordjahr wird ein rekord an schäden durch ebensolche
extremwetterlagen und die treffen vor allem die menschen in den ärmeren regionen dieser welt und rauben ihnen ihre
Komplette existenz die deutsche bundesregierung will helfen und nennt die mögliche lösung
interesse lenz das bündnis bei dem auch andere länder mitmachen soll also armen menschen helfen
sich gegen wetterkatastrophen zu wappnen das konkrete ziel bis 2020 sollen 400 millionen menschen gegen klimaschäden
Versichert sein daumen hoch für diese idee ein erfolg
Im weiteren sinne war außerdem dass ein alternatives bündnis aus us bundesstaaten städte und firmen die offizielle us
Delegation in den schatten gestellt hat auch wenn donald trump plant
Aus dem pariser abkommen auszutreten war das zeichen dieser allianz in bonn deutlich große teile der usa sind weiter dabei sie wollen das pariser
versprechen erfüllen der austritt der usa
spielt so überhaupt, keine rolle mehr auch gut
Immerhin festzuhalten also das pariser abkommen ist nicht geschichte soll fortgeführt und umgesetzt werden der trend weg von kohle ist ungebrochen
man will weiterhin darüber sprechen wie man noch ehrgeiziger
klimapolitik machen kann 2018 soll der sogenannte thaler noah dialog stattfinden bei dem auch umweltschützer und klima, wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen teilnehmen oft sind ja nur die üblichen diplomaten und diplomatinnen eingeladen lange hatten die teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen
Über wichtige finanzfragen gestritten eigentlich sollten die konferenz am freitag enden erst am frühen samstag morgen einigte man sich dann doch darauf
dass ein älterer milliarden schwerer form wohl fortbestehen soll der soll armen ländern dabei helfen
klimafolgen zu bewältigen die chancen sind jetzt größer geworden dass dieser form wohl auch nach dem ablauf des kyoto-protokolls
2020 weiterlaufen soll viele klima diplomaten und politiker feiern den klimagipfel
im bund deswegen als erfolg ganz anders dagegen sehen dass die vertreter derjenigen regionen die schon jetzt unmittelbar
vom klimawandel betroffen sind zum beispiel bei geely nicole wir stehen an der frontlinie des
Klimawandels in ihrer heimat den fidschi inseln mussten schon jetzt ganze dörfer umsiedeln den menschen dort steht wortwörtlich das wasser bis zum hals auch
entwicklungs organisationen wie oxfam sind enttäuscht und kritisieren dass die reichen industrieländer noch immer viel zu wenig verantwortung
übernehmen oxfam mitarbeiter jan kowalzig sagt
Die wachsenden schäden und zerstörungen in folge von dürren stürmen und anderen um wetterextremen
dringend gerade die kleinen inselstaaten zunehmend in
existenzielle nöte auch finanzieller art hier haben die industrieländer zwei wochen gemauert und nun erfolgreich verhindert die
Finanzierungsfragen, im umgang mit verlusten und schäden infolge des klimawandels auf kommenden konferenzen den nötigen raum zu geben das ist ein
übles manöver gegenüber den ärmsten und vom klimawandel
extrem bedrohten ländern der klimawandel in bonn hat vor allem eins gezeigt der vorreiter der deutschland einmal beim klimaschutz war hat nicht nur einige kratzer
abbekommen kaum erreichbar scheint das ziel die treibhausgase bis 2020 gegenüber 1990 um 40 prozent zu reduzieren
Davon haben wir bisher nur 28 prozent geschafft stattdessen ist deutschland kurz davor abgehängt zu werden
deutschland ist weltweit der größte förderer von braunkohle sieben der zehn schlimmsten co2 schleudern in europa stehen bei uns
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel reagiert darauf mehr als ausreichend die interessen von wirtschaft und klimaschutz müssten
sorgfältig bedacht werden in ihrer rede in bonn hat sie zwar einen schnelleren ausstieg aus der kohlekraft
angedeutet wohlgemerkt
angedeutet gleichzeitig betonte sie aber auch dass braunkohle auch weiterhin einen wesentlichen beitrag zur energiegewinnung leisten soll ja echt bullshit
Gleichzeitig wird es auf der erde immer wärmer und das was im klimaschutz bisher vereinbart wurde reicht nicht. Aus um uns zu retten
Deutschland blamiert sich damit so dramatisch auf internationaler bühne wenn wir etwas versprechen ja
Dann, können wir es nicht halten
So gesehen weil der klimagipfel in bonn schon fast eine farce sind auch wenn hier nicht die wirklich großen streitfragen
Besprochen wurden ans eingemachte ging es nicht müsste in dieser situation in der wir uns gerade befinden nicht hart und unerbittlich
Diskutiert werden das hat auf jeden fall nicht stattgefunden es war ringelpiez mit anfassen
Denn die großen probleme wurden nicht weiter angegangen
Wenn ihr in zukunft kein video zum thema verpassen wollt dann drücken wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasst er kein video wenn er hier drauf klickt geht es weiter
mit klimawandel bewiesen skeptiker endgültig widerlegt an johnston bis dann
bleibt dran